my name is Sam Norman Haig nur and I'm a
postdoctoral associate in Nancy
kanwisher and Josh McDermott's lab at
MIT
my lab is interested in the overall
organization of the human brain what are
the parts of the brain and how do they
relate to parts of the mind that's why
I'm interested in this I want to know
who we are as thinkers what the basic
pieces are of the human mind and I think
we can see those by looking at the
organization of the brain so at present
some surprisingly little is known about
the basic organization and functional
properties of auditory cortex which is
the part of the brain that responds to
sounds been involved in processing music
and speech and other other complex
environmental sounds so there had been
many proposals for how human auditory
cortex might be organized into regions
and their association with function but
really very little consensus so the goal
of this study was to try to step back
and take a very broad view of how
humanity our cortex might be organized
and to not really be particularly
reliant on any high pop our hypothesis
about that organization
weas we measured responses using an MRI
in ten different human subjects so what
that means is that we put someone in the
scanner and we played them sounds while
we measured responses with an MRI
machine so in practice we measured
responses to 165 different sounds like
for example for sound of toilet flushing
or the sound of I'm so many cards or the
sound of someone walking they're just
sort of the sounds that we hear and in
everyday life and so the result of that
experiment is that basically we get a
matrix and what that matrix tells us as
it tells us for every point in the brain
how much of that point in the brain
respond to each of the hundred
sixty-five sounds what emerge from from
the analysis was that there's a
relatively small number of functional
properties that seem to dictate the
organization of auditory cortex when we
find that there's about six of these
canonical components that seem to be
able to account for the responses across
auditory cortex in different proportions
in different parts of the brain the
first four components that emerge from
this analysis were aspects of the neural
response to sound that we sort of
anticipated from other work but two of
the components that just popped out of
this very broad screen were striking
selectivity for speech sounds and
striking selectivity for music and that
really blew our minds
so that this result was surprising to us
for for several reasons
one is that when I first came to grad
school I spent basically a year or two
looking for brain regions that respond
selectively to music and basically
failed to find them so going into the
study I actually I I expected not to
find clear selectivity for music in the
explanation for why we were able to see
this clearly with with this method as
opposed to other methods including
methods that we had had previously used
is that that we think that the raw data
of FM rise is spatially coarse and as a
result you need to model the raw data
you need to model voxels as reflecting
multiple things in this case multiple
neural populations and that that
modeling procedure effectively allows
you to resolve patterns of selectivity
that are not able to be seen very
clearly in the raw data so it's it's
it's extremely interesting to to find
some evidence that in fact they're due
there does seem to be neural machinery
that is specialized to some extent for
music perception now what we still don't
really know is like where that comes
from is that something that humans are
born with is that something that emerges
over the course of development because
we get lots of exposure to music and
it's and it's an important and
interesting signal there's a lot of
really deep and open questions that I
think really speak to two fundamental
issues about where music comes from why
we have it and and how it evolved if it
did and so I think the ability to see
this this pup neural population
potentially gives us a method that we
can use to get some leverage on those
questions
you